she said quote she felt no pain anymore
and that God was in control there you go
hey God is in control Jesus take the
whip I mean that
stick around
hey town he's welcome another episode of
dumb people Town population
Nash
it's been a long time coming I'm so
happy you're here buddy what's up guys
how are you welcome back to town buddy
yeah thank you so good to have you first
of all you look great second of all I
love that like the second we get back
together it's like sliding into your
most comfortable shoes yeah like we can
walk Miles by the way there's there's a
clip from apartment 2f 1997 online the
sole clip of IT smash is hilarious clock
pants focus group scene where you're
like yeah what's up with the stitching
on these pants like because Zach says
one thing and then you jump on it and I
was like number one Nash is being
hilarious two he's like a good actor in
this scene yeah it was really fun to see
it and I'm like
oh that's how far we go back I was just
telling my friends about the one of the
funniest things I've ever seen in my
life which I think you guys were there
it was Zach Galifianakis after Andrew
solomonson got bit in the face yes on
your street
we got bit in the face you remember what
Zach said he did he get bit in the face
or punched punched in the face you know
he got bit yeah yeah so Andrew went up
and we were all at embar doing like look
at his like [__] 15 people there or
whatever and Andrew went up and he told
the story and he did well you know and
he's like wow that's a harrowing story
yeah it was funny and then Zach went up
right after him and Zach just walks up
here and he goes well Andrew
I guess you know how those cheeseburgers
feel oh my God
uh Nash you have a question because we
philosophically think about this on the
show all the time but I don't I'm just
roll with it come on no do we think do
you think the world's getting Dumber
like are we hitting a dumb threshold
meaning like even from the last time you
were on the show till now yeah right no
I mean I think the world's pretty smart
we have the internet yeah I love when
this becomes Crossfire yeah oh yeah my
kids are so smart your kids are smart
they're way smarter than me and I don't
know we have everything at our
fingertips so I don't know that's what I
see at least so okay so I'm gonna do a
it can be both ways in that like we have
all the tools to be smarter do we choose
to do it people choose not to so as you
know on the show uh Nashi we get great
stories sent To Us by our awesome fans
there's a new way that we're doing it
and remember Dan had all the stories
last time this time Dan's got a story
Jay's got a story I've got a story and
we're gonna plunge into it and just get
silly great let's do it so I the first
story and let me do is it a trigger
warning should I throw out in advance
you said however you it's your story uh
we don't we don't uh we don't promote
sexual captivity but in this case I
think we can't okay sexual you say
sexual relativity captivity if you
capture someone and torture them with
cats would that be sexual captivity
choosing captivity forever I mean I love
cats but isn't all life with cats on
some level sexual it's at least
emotional like somebody love you they
don't come here I want to sit with you
and the cat's like no I don't like cats
all right here we go uh our brothers are
always funny I said as all cats come
when you call them they just decide when
that's right right they're on their
schedule always they're scared
everything is their schedule hey by the
way thanks to everyone and this is when
we're recording this and I think this
will drop in maybe two weeks who came uh
to San Francisco and saw us at the live
dumb people town at part of sketchfest
you guys are amazing it was incredible
so fun awesome rails just insane that
will come out soon and that was insane
energy but it was just super fun thank
you for that and we'll take a break
we'll be right back
enough stick around make a sound there's
more to people Town hey guys welcome
back to the show we got Jason Nash here
uh a tremendous follow on all social
media and talk about the new uh the
podcast oh new podcast
um all good things it's called I love it
your guests have been wonderful the
stories and things that you guys get
into are wonderful you're also like
crushing it on Tick Tock with your clips
of it yeah absolutely put Clips on there
I like it it's really cool first of all
I love this I love the set I love I mean
I love the the backdrop where is that is
that it's in my house it's in your house
I love it it the vibe of it I know it's
all good things like that vibe in there
and the vibe you create with the guests
is like it feels good it just feels good
to try to do something positive you know
like there's so much negativity on the
internet and it just are you being
negative about the inner about the
negativity look hash you got to be more
positive about the negativity I'm really
proud of the fact that it's something
all right I just wanted to book it a
Feeling we went to see this 80 for Brady
movie the other night yeah yeah and um
with my mom I saw the stuff you posted
about Jake you gotta get it you gotta
get it to me and he and we got to meet
Tom Brady no way and he sat and you know
my mom just loves Tom Brady of course
ultimate ultimate ultimate person Tom
yeah
change New England Jay and he just like
he sat and he talked to her for like
five minutes so cool and I just thought
like oh wow like that guy's just like so
positive and he's like such an
inspiration and so like I you know it it
like reaffirmed like just staying on
track just being positive and just you
did for one second you weren't like
doesn't he have someone else to talk
why
yeah yeah I mean there's a point where
like what if Tom Brady became your dad I
know we were saying that that would be
the greatest thing ever yeah take so
takes your mom out starts dating your
mom just throws the football around with
you I met her at the 80s
Premiere I didn't realize that was my
fetish so uh she's close to 80 so we're
having fun yeah when do when do new
episodes come out uh they come out every
Monday awesome yeah get it wherever you
get it do uh you can watch it on YouTube
you have a YouTube channel yeah most
people except they'll be like I love the
podcast and and then I think oh which
episode they're like well I just watched
the clips
sometimes I haven't I haven't actually
watched a whole episode yeah but I love
the eight seconds of War there you cut
up hilarious I love it I love it and I
do agree with you that like it's very
much a thing that I think we naturally
have done with this show and in general
is to bring positivity and we get that
back from our people from our fans yeah
I'm sure you do too it's a good thing to
put out in the universe it's nice it is
good I love it I agree it's all good
things all good things do you guys have
any dates uh yes we do we uh just added
some dates I'm super excited about but
uh we're gonna be on the outside of
Cincinnati and Lawrenceburg at the
Lawrenceburg Event Center on uh March
4th it's a huge Revenue what's it like
for you guys to go do stand up now okay
we'll talk to you in a while I love it
what's it like what's it like fly
together there are other people with you
is it just the two of you so we usually
bring a feature that we love someone we
love someone we love are they on the
same plane with you no because they're
usually coming from somewhere else got
it so like a lot of times we go with
this guy Jeff Tice who was just with us
in San Diego he's fantastic he's from
Denver so he'll fly from Denver and Zach
Martina who does it he's in Ann Arbor
Michigan and Nate fridson who's in New
York and Nate Abshire is in Minneapolis
so they'll just come and meet us
wherever we are usually a good person
that we enjoy hanging out with and then
uh and we do the weekend of shows and
you know the our hour that we have right
now and I know Dan probably feels the
same way about his hour but our this is
my favorite hour that we've ever done oh
that's great I love it so much and we
don't know where it's going to go well
we've been working really hard at it and
we started doing this thing now in our
shows on the Thursday shows and the late
night shows is we'll just open it up to
questions and we're like let's just
shoot it and then we'll have that as
social media contents to put out so
we'll say like hey this is uh might be
the first time you're seeing us up close
this might be the first time you're
seeing Jews up close I don't know
we'll take five questions and they do
and it has been so fun and it you know
we have already done like 45 minutes of
of or 50 minutes of materials so they've
seen all our stuff and it won't derail
the last thing that we do yeah and it
kind of just fits at the perfect time
he's gonna shoot it so for the whole
thing is a special we're we're thinking
about doing that uh we're also thinking
about possibly writing because a lot of
our stuff has sort of come under the
umbrella of parenting yeah possibly
writing like a two-man Broadway show oh
that'd be really good focusing on
parenting like I'm speaking this out in
the universe because I wanted to like
listen you got to manifest I'm telling
you manifest it it sounds dumb I started
manifesting last year and a bunch of
stuff changed for me so I manifested the
idea for the TV show manifest is that
weird no I mean I really had to I had to
think about it match and then it came
out there speaking of parenting are you
guys doing sports with your kids yes do
you have to drive like insane places yes
and no I mean yes to the extent well I'm
I got lucky that like they're not doing
club stuff they are but like this travel
team turned into a travel league and
they can only play in like one gym and
it's in Burbank you're like yeah Burbank
that's incredible you have to drive to
like but when we were a kid you played
Sports you were kids yeah but I never
did club like in Illinois especially
because every town and where I'm from is
20 miles from the night that's right
people go if you're in club like you're
going forget it they're going to Iowa
they're right you're traveling the other
states Charlie Charlie plays volleyball
we went to New Zealand on Sunday it was
crazy yeah 27 hour flight for one game
and then we flew right layovers yeah
yeah and then he flew right back and
forgot the knee pads oh my God you had
to go back and get the knee back but you
know what it's worth it because you're
not going to get that time back no we
went to Lake Forest Lake Forest which
I'd never heard of before by the way it
could have been Orange County here's
what I heard about the toilets in Lake
Forest they flush the opposite direction
so you're so far down it was so vital
you get up at 6 a.m you get up at 5 30.
pick up two kids
the parents are like thank God thank God
you're doing this we're gonna just bang
every like all morning yeah three games
yeah then they have to ref a game that
they're not even in your kids have to
ref a game yeah yeah and then it's you
know it was like two hours and 15
minutes back oh my God crazy I mean if
what you and you said what you said the
world's getting smarter man come on this
uh let's jump into another story shall
we did oh I didn't even ask you date
since oh we gave one date we gave one
date yeah you do so I'll do the next one
we just added Phoenix we're gonna be in
Phoenix at stand up live at the end of
March the 30th 31st and April 1st we're
at Moon Town we're going to do a live
dumping I'm not official yet but I think
it'll work out I think it's gonna happen
hopefully live dumb people town and moon
tower we're definitely going to be at
moon tower crossing fingers for damn
that I got sure locked up like
Harbaugh's new contract and then uh and
then we're gonna be in Minneapolis at
the Acme Comedy Club we haven't been
there for a really long time that's
gonna be in May May 19th 28th and 21st
yeah I've heard that's a great Club why
is that such a great Club it's amazing
because the a room the scene is really
good yeah a lot of good con they like
love comedy in Minneapolis smart people
it's a great town if not for the weather
like the weather is the thing that keeps
people two and a half weeks of
it's really a great cool town and then
the club itself is just designed
perfectly low ceilings it's like the 280
300 people just last month one time you
guys are telling me about you did like a
like a Sunday show in like Echo Park
outside Festival I think maybe you were
Italian yeah I can't remember and you
were explaining to me about like how the
the for comedy the everything has to be
like perfect oh yeah it's like Mount
Everest stand up yeah yeah and that that
just was not a good yeah so do you
remember yes yeah did you remember
telling me this it might have been the
FY yes I think it was yeah where we're
like out in this tent and like and and
you're just like music playing so loud
right next to you how can we be subtle
when like just be like it's too bad you
take a pause and it's like
and then the person that books you too
is like yeah you guys will go up and do
yourself yeah just do like 40 minutes
you're like no we're not yeah we'll do
like 10 and then there's gonna be
jackhammers but you guys are just doing
fine fine yeah cameras are a great fan
that's great and no one's there to see
you they're just there to take a break
from the music oh my God so it's fine so
that's where we are Daniel you got stuff
coming is the yeah for sure every
Wednesday is the lyric at the lyric
Hyperion is the lyric Comedy Hour it's
Myself and Irene two she's great and she
is awesome you guys are gonna do that
show eventually yes I've already asked
you twice to do it yes and then
um I'm headlining I'm doing the growlics
uh the last weekend in April yes and I'm
also starting a show that I think will
work I'll be there as much as I can but
it should be every single month in
Houston called uh would you rather
comedy where um it's not gonna really
help Comics especially myself generate
new material where Comics come out and
get a random like would you rather
question and you'll start out your set
with that if they spend 30 seconds doing
it they spend four minutes it doesn't
really matter great but it's just a fun
project just showcase show that's going
to take place the secret group in
Houston and a great prompt yeah so love
it I love it it'll be really good yeah
great love it all right ready friends
yes we are let's do this uh this was
sent in by we talking about practice at
not a game underscore not three yeah
great I love it okay woman with
pitchfork and whip arrested outside
Publix in Florida wait a minute
Pitchfork and whip and whip yes and whip
I bet she walked from her car to the
front of the Publix with just the
Pitchfork and was like God damn it God
damn it let me go back God damn it and
then it's like rooting around with
before the who put the whip under the
seat he calls her husband where's my
whip where's my whip I mean if you have
a whip you're gonna use it that's the
problem eventually if you have a whip if
you have a whip in your car and you
don't use it you're like what did I even
get this for so much of my childhood and
you had the whip I know I talked about
it on my own everybody had whips every
kid in Wisconsin bought whips so Dan
just wanted to be Indiana Jones
down at the lake and you're just
whipping people and it wraps around
their ankle and you pull them off the
door someone hot no one died how did you
not all go to the hospital I know no one
put an eye out with the whip we all
whipped each other is it is it easy to
grab someone's ankle with a whip when
it's wet
do it and it just it rips around yeah
it's one of my brothers once yeah they
were standing on a rock and uh and I
just went and I remember even as a child
I couldn't have been more than 12.
even when I pulled their leg out from
under them with the whip and they fell
face first onto the ride I thought as
soon as they hit the water I thought to
myself
the way I'm pulling it the most sense is
that they just go straight like this in
their heads I know I was so tired I
never did it again to uh good that you
live in your family member and I'm sure
the parents who are around watching were
like what do you even do their kids had
whips
don't take that from him you could
probably like whips for Christmas and
stuff if you'd open a new market every
kid would just buy their own way I've
never heard of this it was a weird
chapter on the flea market we're gonna
get
um every town he's listening to this
right now we're like yeah we're gonna
get a cabinet uh we need to get some
flaming I'm gonna run into town for
gross he's gonna stop by just whips yeah
and get you some wet and don't forget to
get a whip for your nephew it's a whip
Christmas do you have time to go to whip
whip
honey are you gonna stop by whips Etc
whip whips limited
Lake County Florida a woman accused used
of waving a pitchfork and black whip in
front of a public store this is the
Florida's level of you gotta you got a
second to talk about kids in need this
is the Florida versus their clipboard
person standing outside do you care
about the environment
how many people in Florida also do you
think unfazed walked right past her
said excuse me to her excuse me excuse
me I just need to yeah no one's asking
you to wear a mask ma'am go ahead this
is according to arrest affidavit the
public the Publix manager told deputies
that Lisa and Sloan Las three first
names was trying to sell what was she
trying to do this is why this is uh Thin
Mints no this is why this is perfect
because as you know like if you ever had
your kids sad to sell things you'll do
whatever it takes
out there you're my rule you sell thin
mints but you buy Samoans okay this is
where the this really became dumb people
Town enough was the Pitchfork and the
whip grocery store right but in Florida
the manager told Troopers uh Sloan where
was I oh no here it's public managers
told deputies that Lisa Ann Sloan was
trying to sell teddy bears behind the
store in Mineola earlier that day
what why would you even bring a
pitchfork and a whip to a teddy bear I
mean you got to drop a business yeah I
guess who wants one of these hey do you
want to go get a teddy bear yeah but get
it from that good woman who has the
Pitchfork where should we buy our teddy
bears from behind the store do you get
your teddy bears where do you get your
teddy bears is that like the store or
carnivals and stuff I prefer to go with
like the woman with a whip and a
pitchfork behind a pumpkin this is
called build a scare nothing good is
happening behind any grocery store no
yeah it's always scary behind a girl
always scary there's flattened boxes and
old fruit
turn the lights on at a strip club
that's like the back of every grocery
store don't like that look at those
smashed cantaloupes the manager told
Troopers that Lisa Ann Sloan used the
Pitchfork to stab a minivan there you go
she's mad that's right the report said
the manager also said the owner of the
vehicle this is another wrinkle
the owner of the vehicle that's the van
that got stabbed with a pitchfork did
not want police involved and would fix
the damage on their own what have they
got going on what does she know about
them what do they know about themselves
in my van yeah I'll take care of it I
don't need you this Nash what is in
there right what are you up to uh
Troopers ordered Sloan to stop it's so
telling Dan 100 so telling she did a lot
of damage to that van well yeah it's
fine it's fine
I'm fine I'm fine Troopers ordered Sloan
to stop but she refused uh to put the
weapon down and then walked away I guess
they just let her go first yeah she's
not stabbing or whipping anyone and she
just gets in her car and goes yeah the
report said that Sloan unbuckled her
seat belt after being placed in a patrol
car and began kicking the window of
course I didn't know they put seat belts
on you I guess they yeah they have to
liability they do yeah yeah yeah they
got to put a seatbelt yeah because if
they don't and something happens and you
own them
according to FHP Sloan appeared to be
highly intoxicated oh
um didn't have an odor of alcohol though
right after being asked about her cut
marks and bruises she said quote she
felt no pain anymore and that God was in
control there you go hey God is in
control Jesus take the whip I mean that
that's the truth Sloan is being held in
the Orange County Lake jail she's being
charged with aggravated assault for the
deadly weapon five thousand dollar Bond
yes I'm gonna ask you guys we'll show
you a photo we'll put it up on the
YouTube If you're not watching there uh
go over to the all things comedy YouTube
channel And subscribe if you're not okay
yeah I'm gonna show you how old do you
think
Lisa Ann Sloan is how old this is
Florida sheet Florida
Pitchfork and whip life I'm just gonna
say she's a teddy bear entrepreneur 32.
she's asking 100 000 for a five percent
stake in her company
she thinks it's a good fit for all of
you sharks right just take it guys okay
what'd you say 32 32.
um I think she's Randy 37 37.
like for real she could be 21 like I'm
not I'm not that's Florida 21.
she lived a life the Pittsburgh 21. I'm
gonna say she's 44. she is
54 years old wow she looks good good she
looks great 84 years old maybe it's the
smile I'm like what are you doing what's
that intermittent fasting yeah well if
you're doing meth you're not eating
unintentional it's pretty good it's a
new thing called unintentional fasting
and if I can't lose this like 10 minutes
yeah whip it into shape she's on the
whip up diet you whip all your food you
have to whip it up all eggs are whipped
everything's whipped people are with a
whip sure so all she did was stab a van
basically that's what that's what she
did they arrested probably didn't have a
license for that and then stabbed them
can you take her in for that Dan no okay
fine but I'm assuming they just started
ringing her up on them let's try and
protect our small business somebody she
was in front of the store and behind the
store in front of the store she probably
looked like a Halloween decoration yeah
and she's whipping things and stuff
who's Manning the teddy bear air rush
that's going on behind the store like
she's whipping people and she's stabbing
me and she's like I gotta get back there
my kids would like to buy some teddy
bears can you stop pitchforking people
in the front yeah leave that van alone I
feel bad for the cops I just came up and
have to deal with that I know it's so
hard at least and they know her yeah
Lisa Lisa over all right that's Story
number two my friends Randy's got us up
next all right give us a tiny teeth hold
on you guys tiny two story number three
she looks good for 50 54. yeah 54. share
the iPad here huh Lisa answer the back
uh we have another extraordinarily
stupid gender reveal and that's we got
coming up after the break again it is
never it is fine to gender reveal that's
totally cool I'm okay with you want to
do that just dial it back dial it back
world you don't need to do this we'll
talk about that on the other side of the
break Jason Ash is with us uh all good
things with it's all good things when
Jason Nash is here with us that's the
name of his podcast check it out not
just the clips be right back
[Music]
hey y'all welcome back to the show we
got Jason Nash here Daniel van Kirk's
here Randy's here let's take us home I
will take you guys home here's the deal
this was sent in by our good friend
Carlene mcdermon at GB Carlene Glover uh
here we go so here's the story couple
contaminate
drought-stricken towns water supply
by dying waterfall blue for gender
reveal oh you just put so much into that
it's not your waterfall is that a
headline or is that the story no that
could have been the whole story that is
not one of you gender reveal did any of
you do no but no yeah so relatively I
would say it's like 10 to 12 years old
right and I had the ultimate thing of
doing that Dan I had the ultimate gender
reveal we didn't know the gender until
the baby came out that's the old that is
the oldest moment like like walk me
through all those seconds are you as
you're looking for the genitalia like so
I
I wasn't even looking I was looking up
at my wife and I was just like you're
like I was at the office yeah maybe I
was doing stand-up no no I was there and
uh and I was at zany someone the worst
name of a place to be at while you're
busy yeah no and uh and we had it the
doctor Doula helping us and another like
Midwife with it there were so many
people in the room too and uh and
someone else shouted it out before I
could see are you serious took away your
moment they said it's a boy and I was
like it's a boy it was still like a huge
moment for me and it was like a big
reveal to me but like I didn't see it
register it and get to you should have
been the first person I should have
everyone should have been like okay we
know what it is take a look yeah you get
that moment to shout it out rather than
or they should be like oh like leave it
at that yay is it not enough of a reveal
to have like you you know a lot of times
somebody will let their one of their
parents or their friends know and then
that's who puts the cake together or
whatever yes is it not enough just to
have everybody get together and have a
good time and then somebody goes just
tells you and then we all are happy I
think we did one more guy started like a
like a you got a one that was an acre
fire because he wanted to shoot it
explosive with an arrow that's it and
that like burnt down yeah like there
were moments where they like get
professional basketball players to dunk
a ball and as it hits them Williams says
Zion Williamson who like how does that
with the ball break ball breaks and then
at the and that yeah
so what if you're having I think if
you're not contaminating the water
supply of a drought strict in town then
you don't love your child that's right
that's not yeah yeah yeah thank you so
the environment Ministry in Brazil like
Brazil needs these types of problems
they have a coup already happening and
zika and everything else is
investigating a couple that had died a
waterfall blue for their gender reveal
party most water Falls are blue am I
right or am I wrong greenish blue well
they're clear and they reflect unless
they're like man-made like uh a few I
know in Wisconsin they lead to somewhere
right it's not just a water we're just
gonna do the waterfall and now it's like
going in everywhere else it doesn't just
end once it hits the from the top to the
bottom what is a waterfall it's just
that's the path of it there's like
nothing for it to the land is it hits
the once it hits the ground or the other
water it's not a waterfall so Dan all
right I'm gonna ask you this our dad
when he was younger and his friends
there was an old Restaurant in St Louis
called Al bakers that was like a St ALB
Baker Steakhouse in Clayton and there
was another restaurant that was really
nice called owls and I'm like unrelated
dad he's like yeah they weren't related
I'm like that's stupid so the two of the
nicest restaurants in St Louis one was
Al's and one was Al makers Al Bakers
probably came second because he's like I
can't call it Alice I gotta call it out
and there was a not a waterfall fountain
a fountain a water fountain in front and
my dad and his friends are our dad and
his friends when we were when he was in
high school like they were put laundry
detergent in the fountain so that's
happened in the town where my family
goes a lot in Wisconsin that's a good
thing that's a good prank that's a good
we're not contaminating the water supply
no yes no that's a good time it's great
it's a great bit it's a little bit
harmless and fun and it's a good life it
is annoying bubbles everywhere
nothing's ruined right so they likely
contaminated the water supply of a
nearby town and the couple face backlash
on the internet see internet's Gonna Get
You Like Jay said the internet's a good
thing we have the internet internet
gonna find you internet gonna get you
all right after they posted a video on
Instagram you could have just
contaminated the water supply and walked
away and just told your friends but you
had to post a goddamn video on Instagram
of the moment the waterfall turned
electric blue to indicate that they were
having a male baby as guests cheered
well I think all the should be like you
cheered this you cheered the
contamination I think what a kid should
have to pay for it for the rest of his
life he will they later deleted the
video video which also showed swans no
made of water balloons dying a giant
question mark symbol made of pink and
blue balloons was also kept by the bank
why didn't you just do the like pop or
what about this what about this what if
the recent
Chinese spy balloon okay
this pink thing comes out and it was a
gender reveal and it's a gender reveal
for like the premiere of China and it or
that China said it's pink and that means
we're going to allow Chinese people
you're allowed to have more than one
girl they legitimately had to stop like
ask people in North Carolina to stop
shooting at that balloon
did they really yes it's like
first of all I'll get it I got it every
centimeter you are off Target and I can
tell everyone who had a gun shooting at
the balloon you're off Target you were
going to end up hundreds of feet away by
the time
anybody who's voting is going to be the
point to where it's not right and you
might get closer than you had if you had
aimed directly at it so now the
unidentified couple is now being
investigated by the Brazilian
environment Ministry which I'm glad that
that just still exists in Brazilian
government remember the Bea uh which
they as they polluted the kamapay river
which is this is horrible a popular
tourist destination in the state of Mato
Grasso Grosso and a primary water source
for the nearby Central West Town of
tangra De Sara they should have to pay
for all this you know that's crazy if
you stood at the bottom of the waterfall
right and you had a friend go over the
top with a whole bunch of blue flowers
and dumped them all like a bucket and
then it would have come down it would
all been blue it would have been part of
nature contaminated nothing all right no
I'd be confused I'd be like I just see
flowers
or the worst is they're dyed and so by
the time they come down the waterfall
they're just white yeah yeah yeah we're
having a white baby what why would you
celebrate that all right so how far from
the central town in kilometers in
kilometers is the waterfall what do you
think I'll go to an even 100 kilometers
100 kilometers close I think it's like
four kilometers okay I don't know what a
kilometer is I don't know that's like a
mile and a half a mile and a half or no
it's like point six seven miles point
six puts in three quarters so your
question is how far out were they how
far out were they because maybe that in
their minds said
because who cares four miles four miles
yeah so that's six kilometers
who do you think it is now you get to
play the game who do you think is
exactly right you want to stay where you
are Nash
1.6 kilometers for every mile 1.6
kilometers for every mile so I'm gonna
go me a hundred kilometers what are you
what's that four and you're gonna stay
with you are you gonna stay all right
the answer is six kilometers
how big how many meters meters now is
God damn it I'm sorry this is Brazil how
many meters tall is the waterfall so
like what kind of a waterfall are we
talking about here right uh how big how
big is it and I think one meter is about
three feet all right yes how many meters
tall is this waterfall that they contain
that they wanted to turn I say 60 feet
60 feet so roughly 20. 20 meters tall
okay
60 feet is like approaching Niagara
Falls no yeah but I run with you Jason I
think they want they obviously wanted to
go big they either go big or you go home
in Brazil ten ten minutes 10 meters so
about that Jay check the meters in the
foot thing it's about three all right I
think it's three feet for every meter am
I right I think that's approximately
right
Niagara Falls is 670 meters okay right
okay that's very far all right so I'm
gonna say three meters three meters it
is the waterfall was 18 meters tall
yeah
and is used for waterfall baths repel
and other tourist activities reported uh
and now they have to shut it down it
said periods of drought have caused
frequent Supply crisis for the
municipality thousands of people comment
on the video slamming the couple for
allegedly putting uh polluted stuffs in
the water once said what happened to
cutting into a cake I love that like now
people are like you did it wrong I'm
gonna give you another suggestion well
that's such an easy one you don't know
what the feeling is it's really pretty I
saw a picture of it right
I'm going to show you we'll post this on
the thing this is the picture of the
waterfall and now she's like I like it
it's blue it's gorgeous it's a huge
gorgeous water that looks like one of
those like flowing paintings that they
have in like Chinese restaurants oh yeah
in a statement yeah where you're like
did you guys [__] up the color on this
thing oh no you didn't uh in a statement
released by the Secretary of State for
the environmental Mato Grasso SEMA
Montague
the department said it will investigate
the couple to determine what products
were used to dye the waterfall and if
there was any environmental damage
gender reveal parties have often in the
past been criticized for extreme stunt
stunts in May last year I was loving an
article gives you another word I mean
last year an explosive device at a
gender reveal party ignited a wildfire
that resulted in the expectant parents
being charged how much how much would
the expected parents first of all really
quick sure
we don't know these people might have
done it smart because they said it
contaminated the water but they have yet
to find out if there was any actual
chemical environmental damage yeah what
if you could so maybe they were like hey
[__] food coloring to be out of the
water in two hours
right so the people who started a
wildfire that's how I think we were
talking about how much would they find
this is good 250 000 250 000 what do you
think all right three million dollars
Jay Woody seven million I only think
because I think we did this story you
guys are you were mad that they start a
wildfire you're going to be even more
mad when I tell you how much they were
fined 500 oh that's it for starting a
while we did why are we disco why aren't
we discouraging more people you got to
be punitive with that stuff it's got to
ruin your what's explosive about the
powder like why does it catch fire so if
the powder is intense right yeah so they
put explosives and they fill the
explosives with the powder so when the
explosive blows up that it sends the
powder into the air and then you know
pink
there you go and that is uh there's
Story number three and that's on the
show what a good time Jason Nash I love
you buddy all good things it's all good
things to you man all good things you've
always you're a solid man dude I think
we're 10 years ago I did that thing for
Nerdist uh the TSA Michael kissick TSA
and you played uh you played my boss it
was just that quick little short thing
you did and you were was it was it was
your schedule yeah and you were just
pitch perfect wonderful
man uh Randy and I have always said
Jason Ash is one of our favorite sketch
comedians on stage performers all this
stuff it's so cool just because she'd
commit to a bit I mean that was my only
criticism
succeeding and having a following and
people supporting you because it makes
us happy you know it was funny the show
you mentioned uh apartment 2f the one I
was on yeah Bill Byrd did stand up yes
he did in that episode right yes on that
episode here's who did stand up in on on
our show Bill Burr did it uh it might
have been his first might have his first
TV set Patton Oswalt did it yeah
Patrice and patton both did and Bill
Burr did stand up on Norton Jim Norton
did stand up on the show I mean
unbelievable show apartment to have back
in the day you were a part of it you've
always been a part of everything we've
done thank you guys thanks for having me
I love it and no [__] guys we gotta get
back to work
town
[Music]